today i've received a
fixed penalty notice from the
metropolitan police relating to an event
in downing street on the 19th of june
2020 and let me say immediately that
i've paid the fine and i once again
offer a full apology
and in a spirit of
openness and humility i want to be
completely clear about what happened on
that date
my day began shortly after 7am
and i chaired eight meetings in number
ten including the cabinet committee
deciding kobed strategy
i visited a school in hemel hempstead
which took me out of downing street for
over four hours
and amongst all these engagements on a
day that happened to be my birthday
there was a brief gathering in the
cabinet room shortly after 2pm
lasting for less than 10 minutes
during which people i work with kindly
passed on
their good wishes and i have to say in
all frankness at that time
it did not occur to me uh that this
might have been a breach of the rules
but of course the police have found
otherwise and i
fully respect the outcome
of their investigation
i understand the anger that many will
feel that i myself fell short when it
came to observing the very rules which
the government i lead had introduced to
protect the public
and i accept in all sincerity that
people had the right to expect better
and now i feel an even greater sense of
obligation to deliver on the priorities
of the british people strengthening our
economy creating jobs and opportunities
leveling up across the whole of the
united kingdom uh now of course ensuring
that putin fails in ukraine and easing
the burden on hard-working families
caused by higher energy prices
i will take that forward that that task
with
due humility
but with maximum determination to
fulfill my duty and
do what is best for the country i serve
thanks very much
this does make you the first serving
prime minister to have been found to
have broken the law it's a serious
matter will you resign
i
have of course
paid the uh
the fpn and i apologize once again for
the mistake that i made and
as i've said just now i want to be able
to
get on and deliver
the mandate that i have but also to
tackle the
problems that the country
must face right now and to make sure
that we get on with delivering for the
people of this country that is that is
my priority
the problem for you though is to do that
people have to trust you voters have to
respect you uh they have to think you
have authority isn't the fact that you
broke your own laws
doesn't that mean that you can't do that
i believe that it's my job to get on and
deliver for the people this country and
that's what i'm going to do but this
wasn't an isolated incident you've made
clear you think it was just 10 minutes
it wasn't one isolated incident there
have been 50 fines so far
do you take responsibility for a culture
in downing street the place that you
live but also the place where people
work where people thought that this kind
of behavior was acceptable
of course i take full responsibility for
for everything vicky but don't forget
that dining street is
about
you know 15 000
square feet it's a it's got a lot of uh
officials working at hundreds and
hundreds of uh officials i couldn't be
everywhere at once but clearly once it
became obvious what had been happening
the the types of uh
of behavior that unfortunately sadly
we'd seen we've taken steps to change
things and downing street has been
radically transformed uh it's a much
it's a very different uh organization
and we're we're focusing 100 on
delivering our agenda but you did
repeatedly say that all the guidelines
were followed in downing street that was
a lie wasn't it
uh when i said that i spoke in
completely good faith because as i've
said to you just now i at the time that
i was standing up for uh nine minutes in
the in the cabinet uh room where i work
every day it didn't occur to me that i
was you didn't understand your own rules
and everyone told me that uh as i say
that i was in breach i now humbly accept
that that i was
um but i think the best thing i can do
now is having settled the uh the fine is
is is focus on the job in hand that's
what i'm going to do do you think more
fines are coming your way
uh you know i i i
if they're if they are i'm sure that you
will be the first to know my monks are
very first today okay
thank you